all right ready and action
you
one even drag it out longer don't we get
a close-up on each other
so we're choosing you you're choosing
your weapons for this everyday if it
doesn't matter what weapon it is you
know if anything the more over the top
the better I always let the actor cheer
all right
hmm I feel like Tamra come out with a
bow and arrow
Hey oh that may be I feel like I should
just have like the biggest sword a
little giant scimitar there yeah yeah
all right now yes so like when you bring
up you for bringing this back honey is
it I everybody I would cookie okay
something like like that you know like I
like I said I'm sure actually which you
may be able to cheat it and put your
thumb on the other side here to hold it
in place yes my weapon of choice I was
looking at that I was like I really want
to use this yeah well not sure weapon of
choice
oh it's so big this just I'm not
compensating it I I wasn't gonna make
that you weren't there
coin what's this
okay oh boy loose okay cool and you got
that so all right
oh that's a nice one yeah some chopped
Sun sheriffing probably need um either
Jim or Rob to get this case seriously
Malcolm I'm getting a contact high off
of your aftershave I know I like it is
like sniffing glue okay
not Malcolm's he was surprisingly hair
on his face it does and thank you oh wow
thank you oh my god I never pass a
moment know that I didn't realize I was
getting it until it's just my hormones
guy no I have to share pheromones yes
sure okay can I like film it from 18
feet away yeah sorry it's like yeah
surprisingly like it was a few days cuz
I didn't get a chance to shave because
you know the cod and panels and stuff
and did you just buy turpentine and snow
it's some pecan were you at uh mff what
is that Midwest for fest okay cuz we
were in Chicago
and we just saw some furry I'm like it's
gotta be a convention I'm like suddenly
that furnitures you okay done
it's like ah you know but uh yeah
actually uh got invited to do a panel
there voice acting panel yeah Louis pack
voice acting fists of furry no it was it
was a voice acting it was furry roads no
fast in the furriest
the faster the ferries at fifteen
fucking the road it wasn't very broke Oh
puns oh I love though he said Oh
yeah my favorite piece of classical
music is Fur Elise okay Beethoven humor
okay so it was a great turnout
it was packed I get approved for a
bigger it's the malcolm effect
it's the malcolm effect okay where where
I am okay waiting that way so do I have
hit your head I'm sure I'm gonna show
you all right see what you do is you
hold like this and this goes they're
gonna uh Tamara turnout to shoot me
missus yeah
with something that's sharp
hey it's really gay yeah that could
leave a very small bruise this is a very
better shot there you go that's pretty
small I'm sure I figure how to do fast
cuz I think it's like down and then flew
right uh yeah but you can maybe see
here's the thing here's maybe she could
already have it drawn yeah that's what
I'm saying see here here's the shot
you're both gonna be on either side of
the door so like Malcolm you'll be here
at Amory over here I'm gonna be outside
going freak oh no I mean like you can be
up here oh well yeah but you you want be
sure you're not blocking the there so
yeah go ahead take like three steps for
both of you not right there yeah so I
I'm gonna be outside shouting for you
could we recruited fruity critic ah free
critic I'll take it some Malcolm you
City it starts off with uh yeah Malcolm
using a critic and you sort of point to
the younger me out there crude okay oh
yeah and Jim approaches have you say
this um have you say I never thought I'd
say this but you have my permission to
beat the shit out of me you know as the
critic and after he says that that's
when you to hold up your weapons like
she and you start to go outside
wrestling gotta be using all right yeah
yes yes II see if maybe like that
effects seen you can put more than this
hand there you go okay I'm gonna try one
with Tamara the one with the both of you
Kazan shit just as soon as you step to
the frame I'm like oh man tree that
might be pretty fox glacier
looking really evil yeah and definitely
you know show you there you see
oh gosh as I see you phone so you can
hold it kind of like this I mean you're
just like an evil you know very very
evil genius you oh yeah don't get
anxious
oh yeah I'm just gonna look a lot give
it give it give it
thanks Rob right girl like you yeah
Malcolm you're just gonna be sitting
there just like a little more like ruff
there it's for you guys let's look at
that hat on the table or well just like
that area I guess is where I'm like and
you're gonna be doing the button press
uh yeah she's just gonna be see if he
can have it out a little bit more yeah
there he goes we can see that yeah
that's actually and you're definite
you're definitely showing teeth Tamara
yeah big all right
yeah okay so looks you both just have it
I was amazing just go ahead and keep
that
I'm ready and action I'm gonna do one
more just still alright same faces other
and action
okay stuffing Tara's evil you server the
jabber well Jim can you grab that way
we're gonna bring them into this room
and you might even get on the show a lot
that's gonna shoot because they like me
in those storage closet I knew I was
gonna shoot this I just shoot Andre
still there just Oh dad put you back
after we do that would be illegal
yay boxes weird like I'm he's nothing
right it's just so sweet it's like Mario
Kart on Disney yeah with some kind of
gaming game show yeah is that what it
was I chaos just like ya know I tried
rate uh he was like later on the Disney
Channel it's some sort of like gaming
with gamers or something like that it's
just a bunch of kids and some youtubers
I guess like just playing Mario car and
it's like it's not great the black
mirror that's just like oh okay yeah
like he's just aa nerd he's just playing
I'm just gonna do like the Disney
trailer guy and Andre the black nerd
yeah we did G no you got do it like this
is heartwarming but it's cool ABC Family
african-american or be the black nerd no
it's like me ABC family it's gonna put
the fuckin gentling it yeah why think Oh
fam uh something stupid in history
that's a great time right no right
something stupid would be better the
hell was it uh the something was that it
was something with a network I feel like
oh my god it was terrible
i I just like what was wrong with ABC
Family and actually it's worked all this
time yeah I guess they felt like a ruby
in English necessary I can't
how am I gonna get my fucking
hocus-pocus fix they rebrand and they're
running hocus-pocus again next year or
Nightmare Before Christmas or home alone
but you still haven't seen
I've seen it Oh or Jim
Malcolm hissing something on you Jim you
a child of the eighties yeah
child of the 80s nothing
come on no the old man here is like man
I second it I raised my boys right they
saw him like 17 times pay for it
we didn't have a Christmas that year
ironical we did it was a homolog oh oh
whoa
we had no tree nothing it's very sad oh
thanks dad but yeah what about home
alone road to forgiveness hey have you
seen that gone Road to Perdition to
forgiveness have you seen it a road chip
to forgiveness yes
okay I won't work ahead Terry you're
going to act like you just like the door
you locked me in here and you're gonna
turn around
Oh Rob I can't get the shut yeah uh
you're gonna be the one handed it I have
a cane in the other okay decision oh
okay haters in it it was my great I
would see that so I actually would
probably see that twice that you would
get you haven't seen it I have seen that
that's hilarious
that's using the movie though it says
nice Connie you've been fighting so much
harder Steph just I've seen that too
late now look at my lightning it's gonna
be like clockwork orange' young I share
all I was open yeah yeah okay so
plaintiff I'm a colleague I just okay
you wanna see it
okay Rob so uh I'll go ahead see your
guard over here they follow them Bonnie
they're just gonna all you're gonna do
laughs you're gonna be hearing you
you're just going to turn around like
that so so the camera just that's all
from her okay and you're not in the
shout at all correct
gosh what we are they looking at you yes
if I hear what I did just just run
through so we get the eyeline so Rob
going go
gonna be lookin you to turn around say
good I like for them
sure okay just fine okay a little
tighter on a camera there you go okay
okay and action
wonderful now the Nostalgia Creek will
be like the old days
memes memes and whatever lying to you
after me and Zaha he'll give us some
more important role right
oh yes they say you're supposed to drink
eNOS they're not mine is my clock yeah
what we'll do are evil just as soon as I
say actual track in and action okay guys
it's ready yeah action good I'm going
I'm a seasoning it yeah we're just oh
yeah yeah we're going to a whole thing
from the beginning well and I'm out
consider mine just a hint slope okay
sure all right okay ready and action
wonderful now in the staffs Creek will
be like the old days nothing but clips
memes and there's time an actual review
of the movie
haha you'll give us a more important
role right of course
good ok cool
this one's just going to be flipped
around it's going to be me and yeah I'm
just gonna say the exact same thing you
know that just said exam I think of
course that's when you even track in
again like the evil spot okay
okay ready and action
wonderful now miss Tasha Creek will be
like the old days nothing but cliffs
means and there's time an actual
analysis of the movie hahaha you'll give
us a more important role right of course
this tear gland set pretty bad and
action
wonderful now quiet you action excellent
now the nostalgia critic will be like
the old days nothing but quits memes and
there's time an actual analysis of the
movies
hahahaha and you'll give us a more
important role right of course
big terrorist I might actually do that
just for the hell of it get get them
cause we gotta do an L well you don't
need to track in it's already tied off
but yo just do when you go to the store
to sell I like what's all okay it's all
free to make bobble days uh uh it
doesn't keep oh yeah that's right you
get rid of it okay all right so you're
looking to be still and just just pretty
much follow me whenever go that's when
you do the big mouths and stuff but I'll
just do it like maybe three or four
times just follow me pretty much excited
are we just smiling normally or we do in
the Eagle spot you go just ahead oh hey
long children there cuz that is
identical
okay alright ready
I want to even drag it out longer don't
we get a close-up on each other it's
good here just do a few of those again
if you Malcolm get in there just took my
Duncan do it again
so essentially rob pretty much came up
with the tie yeah pretty much because I
always wore a different shirt underneath
for the first like four or five videos
and then we're doing the Harry Potter
event as gay interests out of Rogers
likes Mises you know it's a big event to
wear a tie and like that's a great idea
and I just knew the white shirt like
that's only thank could go with this is
I put it on it just won't the way look
down like I think I'm keeping this I
think it looks the first thing he said
me and I tied it for him he's been doing
it ever since
oh and what about the Hat
I mean the hats there from day one um
but I had well just get that hat from
Mike I said no no I was just my normal
hat I wore and then like I lost it the
Harry Potter event so I defined it I
want I couldn't find one that that was
you know the traditional cast square
shape so I got one that looked like this
that looked awful I didn't wear it in
that many videos but it's then my wife
before just my wife got me the new hat
she found one that looks just like the
old one I used that for years but yeah
this one was like it just looked really
really bad cuz it looks like a really
old school and 80s baseball hat kind of
thing yeah weirder now pitching for the
White Sox like yeah again it was one of
those things for its like I was trying
to tell like there's gonna be two of us
in this how you gonna tell us apart you
know cuz I can't just go it doesn't make
myself a little chubby with all the time
you know um so I figured like a
different color shirt in the different
hand that seems to work oh I won't say
about getting like really really baggy
pants but again that would just take too
much time to keep changing out of them
the whole time so I decide not to do
that true
standing up like this and then your
freshener is Darwin dude here there you
can that we can shirt off oh you're
gonna be certain about this man yeah
it'll be a day-long shop I'll still be
ok yeah ok I don't work here go ahead
and see good going to try the track and
let's make sure it's not gonna get away
the lady why not I'll make a trip for
the lighting that's fine okay alright
guess I better get back here when Doug
was me as he was holding the camera way
over here so it appeared it appeared
what so it appeared that you were
actually tracking through the couch he
held the camera way over here yeah but
he wants us from the critics point of
view
well the present critic is gonna be yeah
the critics gonna be sitting in the
chair we're gonna have to cheat it a
little bit so I mean like yeah just
starting like right here sort of going
wait so you wanted that low yeah cuz the
gray is going to be sitting while he's
giving those beats to the camera okay so
so I don't want it where I'm necessarily
looking up I think that's it probably
probably the door knob there will be our
eyeline when we turn alright whenever
you're ready I'm gonna say okay get the
hell out of here you know you're uh okay
get the hell out of here you're exactly
like this movie you think never changing
and repeating the same traditions over
and over is what's important then as I
say that I'm gonna start walking for is
a metaphor for the audience isn't it
yes thank you I was just chatting over
today you did it you doing thank you
thank you
then Tamra always to bringing three
wishes
if that makes it on that's our running
joke for Jessica Jones cuz apparently a
lot of people would come in to rob
saying like it's a rape metaphor like
well what's the metaphor I don't Li's
come to me these are just articles being
passed around the internet oh okay it's
a great metaphor it's like a good
metaphor for a preview it and like but
they're written as if this was some
shock or surprise I'm like imma leave on
episode 1 and without reading any of
that I'm like oh it's like a rape
metaphor and like but the way these
articles are written but it's like is it
you get it and I'm like I got in an
episode one way is that even a better
word with a general gist is more
straight-up raise so we just so we say
it's a ring like our week letter so it's
a great benefit they sculpt you know and
second thought let's not including any
of this it'll just be one up okay so I
still gotta watch the rest of Jessica
Jones oh I know I'm only on Episode one
I come back army goes have some TVs but
you see I was just like oh one of your
point - Gary's like left I'm just gonna
put here that stand for Tamara this this
is so cool this is oh my god it was so
she really just made that after we got
back from watching that is incredible
with that's some stuff I had learn room
there's my mom in some no tape Tamara
have you seen the Star Wars yeah yes
I've seen the Star Wars the stars just
just double checking the War of the
Stars she's telling since you know Mom
hey that's a little bit better than
hello okay let's not go narcs at least
I've seen not my mind okay you know none
of the prequels are better than over
well but the originals yes I would
concede the originals of every level but
not the prequels okay
let's go five isn't everyone but that is
horrible
yeah that's Jim Craig but I needed her
paint cans here Anakin in the face
you wonder as to me my powers heads up
oh you guys give up you thirsty young to
make this whoo yeah that'd be amazing
we're trying to share don't event
inferior loser candy Oh nobody eats
Smarties shut up what's in it so you
tell me I'm wrong you're wrong
no you're wrong Smarties suck you know
oh she's the one oh good for you
no nose somebody needs to that way we
can keep the loser candy monster away
from gravity falls
oh yes she's our defense okay all right
okay we will shoot this thing okay ready
mm-hmm
action Tamara turn that music off why
just do it don't ever do that again and
make me have those incredibly normal
spasms come on this one do it like cuz
the music's gonna be very loud so I mean
just y-you know it's like the music's
very loud why okay I'm turning it off
okay okay ready and action
Tamara turn that music off why just do
it don't ever do that again to make me
have those incredibly normal spasms good
we'll do one more here melts against the
couch yeah you balanced a camera your
lady like you did it all right ready
hmm and action Tamara turn that music
off why just do it thank God
don't ever play that music to make me
those incredibly normal spasms again
every day good to do the free client
Walmart I just freak yeah yeah just do
it from freak ok whatever you ready do
all the while wait before it I want to
be ready good do it while looking down
Oh what are those Wow your giant
Smarties I just have it's because I need
to press they sell these glucose tabs
for low blood sugar but they're super
freaking expensive and these are like
five cents that's true and if you have a
medical condition then hey that's the
only legit way I don't want to take one
okay okay cuz II I'm okay on smart ways
I don't love those it's all the same
yeah say that way you won't get a
stomachache I really do these have the
same effect as Tom's I don't probably
not yeah ah very that's how they make
Smarties look Bernie eat this Giants
Mario I think I'd rather die than have
one of those I like them alone yeah
they're fun yeah yeah I don't like loser
candy all right like I agree with you
you're like solid forms a pixie stick oh
yeah yeah that is freaking like a good
thing yeah you get like Toffees they
would hand out around oh no no not those
no the orange they come in the orange
and black rappers you know what I'm
talking about it yeah you're no yes okay
this translated fruit like little
strawberries or something's like no your
mother used to not want to Bruce but hey
those were terrible
I didn't like those a mess no oh no
smart us and I no one likes candy corn
though oh yeah
oh hey or should they wash it no I don't
like candy corn though that's where I
draw the line
candy corns like shut up a bitch
have you ever seen Lewis blacks routine
oh my god
every year through the internet room I
hear candy corn is good with popcorn
though like gourmet pop are real yes why
I was told by like this candy uh I think
the texture is one word I'm careful oops
thanks textures I thought would be too
different no like it has to be made like
specifically by uh the ones that make a
licorice like these Swedish candy makers
it's appropriate to make it apparently
yeah it comes out on third oh this is
the burnt oh wow fire retardant but it's
a great fire retardant watch we'll get
some comment like that assist you you
said they don't have to use that
yeah it is there for something yeah I
was like well thanks then so I said I'll
just bring it to the studio cuz I just
wanna be seen on video - right there you
go yeah I'm sure we do music cool well
thanks whoever donated this maybe elf
send it to us yeah well that's why I
thought I was talking about like you
know what the censored bros music oh no
he's like no guy just gave me this at a
con right yeah yeah he said ah here you
go
I was like okay thanks see I know I'll
just bring it to the studio then and
maybe he can't I don't know right no no
no we can we can heat up the thing we'll
just do that and pull it down okay yeah
that'd be cool what you said
it's just beautiful looks like it might
actually do something to right
I'm glad the indented PVC yeah that's
all these are PVC ten Isis yeah and when
it's done up in the right way it looks
like something from a sci-fi movie wow
you look so Jedi like that's listen I
sing any was a research me profound
compliments yeah so someone gave me a
censor bar while I was at the convention
I heard that that's awesome
yeah oh it's a cop I think it's a
callback to one of the jokes that was
done in a soldier Creek where he had to
slap a censor bar and everything yes I
feel like that was a thing I forgotten
what it was I don't know do you revert
in I dunno Oh
they do indeed a little pig that'll do
hmm hey peeking the city dude directed
by the guy you do fury road wow really
yeah
yes get somebody followed it up with to
what beefy wow he's just a versatile
director I guess the guy who did the man
Master Li Jie and fury road also did
happy feet they gave that to him he's a
talented bad it made pic of the city too
he didn't do the first babe he wanted to
something he stopped doing something but
I believe he was like one of it
co-writers really your service or
something out and then yeah he ended up
doing the sequel things with my sequels
Darko got like three weird bones yeah oh
is it on this wow yeah sup Jedi nothing
like shit I may the power of
midi-chlorians compel you I am count
rekt food yeah nice work uh-oh
hey there's a gonna break you are proper
it looks like they are proper the hoax
air popper adults yes
Darth robbed every unlike how Braveheart
get my three lines we will return again
it'll be good like burned your hand off
I need a regular right it's really weird
it's hard to like it kind of don't you
think you'd have the advantage you have
to get more aggressive Rob you know hate
you like eat I'm not a scratch haha you
know I don't mean I do want to do more
des I don't yeah you don't really like
right you just use one end if it cuz
twirling it is like a wasted why don't
like 118 I guess are we really just
about to do this
say does that split enhancer dad oh
pretty good yes something else on God
yeah yes something like you got just an
hour clause or something just something
a tad bigger but yeah I think we'll be
good let me just give you their ear does
it split in half yeah we are you are
dead so let's give you a robot Jimmy
when it's all put on Oh Cherie thank you
if this with this camera are yours okay
George it seems like you have to fix it
yeah it'll be gone but again yeah of
course check you're dead I feel like her
was like in fencing at some point this
is gonna be the entire behind-the-scenes
keep it here yo come
feels great looks great oh I think so
do we have the UM we have a different
come you see look like a like a white or
something like that
WIC ANSWER I mean we don't get by this
one Bundy I'll just show me what you
mean
well it's like a turban yeah oh did I
know me
Sikh yeah if we have something a little
longer Jim we can make a turban out of
it okay I know it's just that smells bad
as looking little girl I've ever seen
right outfit something it's just like
okay good for her ah oh wait wait there
is one let me I want one with like the
gaga
Oh Rob Skywalker yeah wasn't that the
death of - food - yeah yeah now that's
why he had all the frosting removed
I'll turn a little this way ah
Gilligan - sit hello Jedi me says that's
not true you're not my father the
collegiate I need to search your
feelings you know it to be true if I
realize I'm a sane person therapy and a
little sober bring it up
a little higher to start also we can see
okay maybe like the Lord's cannot eat
frosted mini-wheats
they have no child inside the house just
yeah they don't get it
okay you know do reassure them say fuck
Evers I didn't do it it it just toss the
spoon to get it
okay ready oh boy god dammit maybe a
smoothie oh and then go ahead just stand
still I'll get like a few shots you two
again just in kissing game just like
close up shots and everything I don't
think I've seen a lot of Dutch angling
going out on the trail it's the channel
of some version Dutch angle I don't have
to it's only when you and Tamara are in
the same shit of a height difference I
kind of have to be like yeah okay you
get a yes